the data today we're not really 100%
sure yet what the significance is as
we're feeling our way through this
number of people tested 18,000 positive
cases are up 8,000 total of 122 thousand
cases number of patients discharged
total discharged up is 12,000 1,700
discharged in one day number of deaths
is up that's the bad news
it's 44,000 159 and we pray for each and
every one of them and their families and
that is up and that is the worst news
but the number of deaths over the past
few days has been dropping for the first
time what is the significance of that
it's too early to tell this is the
impact by state but as I said the
interesting blip may be in the data or
hopeful beginning of a shift in the data
in the number of cases total number of
new hospitalizations is 574 which is
obviously much lower than previous
numbers that's partially a function of
more people being discharged but you see
ICU admissions are also down the daily
intubations down slightly from where it
was again you can't do this day-to-day
you have to look at three or four days
to see a pattern discharge rate is way
up and that's great news and the
statewide balance of cases has been
relatively stable for the past few days
there is a shift to Long Island upstate
New York is basically flat and as Long
Island grows the percentage of cases in
New York City has reduced this is when
for those people who look at the data
there is a you have all these projection
models and what's been infuriating to me
as the models are so different that it's
very hard to plan when these models
shift all the time but there's also a
difference of opinion on what happens at
the apex right everybody all the models
say you go up until you go down thank
you very much
then there's a difference of is the apex
a point or is the apex a plateau in
other words do you go up hit the high
and then immediately drop or do you go
up and then there's a plateau where the
number of cases stays high for a period
of time and then drops there's a
difference of opinion so you have to
think of that when you think about what
you're seeing in the numbers because you
could argue that you're seeing a slight
plateauing in the data which obviously
would be good news because it means you
plateau for a period of time and then
you start to come down and we're all
feeling our way through this and we have
the best minds in the country literally
literally on the globe advising us
because New York is the first I also
think it'll be very helpful for the
other states that follow I was just
talking to dr. Zucker about codifying
everything we're learning because when
the next states start to go through this
we hope that they can benefit from what
we're going through but we're looking at
this seriously now because by the data
we could be either very near the apex or
the apex could be a plateau and we could
be on that plateau right now we won't
know until you see the next few days
does it go up does it go down but
that's that's what the statisticians
will tell you today as we've said before
the coronavirus is truly vicious and
effective at what the virus does it's an
effective killer people who are very
vulnerable must stay isolated and
protected I mean that was the point from
day one that was the point with
Matilda's law my mother you have to
isolate and protect those people if a
very vulnerable person gets infected
with this virus the probability of a
quote-unquote cure is very low and
that's what this has really been about
from day one that small percentage of
the population that's very vulnerable
major effort that has impacted everyone
to save the lives of those people who
are in the very vulnerable population if
you're not involved part of that
vulnerable population then you will get
sick 20 percent require hospitalization
but the hospital system is very
effective and it makes a real difference
and that's why the highest number of
people ever now being discharged right
so you're just seeing the evolution of
this whole story you're seeing their
narrative unfold right we're all
watching a movie we're waiting to see
what the next scene is and as the movie
unfolds you start to understand the
story better and better rush of
infection rate rush of people into the
hospital system hospital system capacity
explodes more people are in but more
people are coming out 75 percent of
those people have now gone into the
hospital system are coming out of the
hospital system it also helps with the
capacity of the hospital system because
obviously the more people who are coming
out it makes it easier to handle the
large influx that's coming in having
said all of that the operational
challenge for the healthcare system
is impossible because the system is over
capacity all across the board it's just
over capacity so what we're basically
saying to assist them is you have to
manage with the same resources that you
have same staff an overcapacity
situation and that is putting a
tremendous amount of stress on the
healthcare system you're asking a system
to do more than it has ever done before
more than it was designed to do with
less I understand that and I get that
and day in and day out the Commissioner
and everyone at this table deals with
the healthcare system I I understand
what they're dealing with I understand
they're being asked to do the impossible
and they are being asked to do the
impossible but life is options and we
don't have any other options so you get
to a situation and you do what you have
to do in that situation and that's where
we are the only operational plan that
can work right because you know the
system doesn't have the capacity doesn't
have the supplies doesn't have the staff
so how do you handle this surge over
capacity we call it we have to surge and
flex which means you have to deal with
if you're an individual hospital or
hospital network yes you're going to be
over capacity and the only way we can
make this work is if we flex the system
so that we take all hospitals all
hospital networks some hospitals or in
networks and we work together as one
system which has never been done right
we have public hospitals we have private
hospitals we have Long Island hospitals
we have New York City hospitals in
totality it's the health care system the
state manages regulates the health care
system but they're all individual
hospitals and or individual networks and
they are custom
- just doing business and managing their
own affairs
that doesn't work we have to balance the
patient load among all of these
hospitals so if one Hospital starts to
get high or has a projected high intake
we have to shift that patient load to
other hospitals that means some patients
who show up at their neighborhood
hospital may be asked can we transport
you to another hospital which is not in
your neighborhood but actually has more
capacity so we have to adjust that
patient load
among all of the hospitals which is a
daily exercise and it's very very
difficult we're running short on
supplies all across the board some
hospitals happen to have a greater
supply of one thing or another one
Hospital has a greater supply of masks
one Hospital has a greater supply of
gowns and when we're talking about
supply hospitals they're accustomed to
dealing with 60 day supply 90 day supply
we're talking about two or three or four
day supply which makes the entire
hospital system uncomfortable which I
also understand because we're literally
going day to day with our supplies with
our staff etc which is counter intuitive
and counter operational for the entire
healthcare system and I understand that
also the big operational shift will be
that Javits coming online if we get that
up and running efficiently that's 2,500
beds for people who test positive with
the Kovach virus that is a major shift
for the systems and at a time when we
desperately need a relief valve for the
system Javits could do that so we're
working very hard to get that up and
running but that rolling deployment that
flexibility
there is no other way to do that to do
this on the state level you know I can't
say to a hospital I will send you all
the supplies you need I will send you
all the ventilators you need we don't
have it we don't have them it's not an
exercise it's not a drill it's just a
statement of reality you're going to
have to shift and deploy resources to
different locations based on the need of
that location I think that's going to be
true for the country the federal
government everyone says the federal
stockpile federal stockpile there's not
enough in the federal stockpile to take
care of New York and Illinois and Texas
and Florida and California it just it's
it's not an option the only option I see
is there's a national deployment
everybody says this is wartime it is a
war and the virus is the enemy we're New
York helped New York today
Thank You state of Oregon we're dealing
with this curve today in this intensity
and then nationally we shift the
resources to the next place that is most
impacted right just what we're doing in
New York City in New York State on a
microcosm we shift resources from the
Bronx to Brooklyn to Queens to Nassau
shift national resources and state
resources from New York to Florida to
Illinois whatever is next on the curve
we're going to do that in any event we
get through this people have been so
beautiful to us and it is the New York
way we're going to codify everything
we've learned and we get past this curve
whatever part of the country goes next
we will be there with equipment and
personnel and however we can help
federal government is also deploying
approximately 1,000 personnel to New
York that's doctors at the nurses it's
respiratory technicians
the immediate priority is to deploy
those people to help the New York City
public hospitals the New York City
public hospital system HNH was a system
that was under stress to begin with
before any of this
so obviously you had more stress to
institutions that were under stress it
only makes the situation more difficult
so we're going to deploy all the federal
personnel who are coming in today 325 to
the New York City public hospital system
I talked to the hospital administrators
on a daily basis we get them on a
conference call and we do this shifting
of supplies and balancing of patient
load
I know that I'm asking them to do really
difficult things I get it I don't enjoy
being in this situation
I don't enjoy putting them in this
position I know their staff is all
overburdened but all I can say is thank
you to the administration of this
healthcare system and most importantly
thank you to the frontline workers I
mean these people they are true heroes
in the truest sense of the word what
they do day in and day out under very
difficult circumstances and we thank
them all on a different somewhat lighter
note there's an accompanying affliction
to the corona virus that we talked about
early on
it is cabin fever it is a real situation
not medically diagnosed is doctors okay
there's no medical definition for cabin
fever but I believe it exists it's a
feeling of isolation it's often
accompanied by radical mood swings
resentment of people around you varying
degrees for no reason whatsoever just an
upwelling of resentment especially
towards people who are in apparent
positions of authority in the situation
which I've noticed irrational
bursts can comment at anytime without
any warning just a irrational outburst
frustration anger with no rational basis
cabin fever in many ways also threatens
the essence of our Constitution which is
premise on people
ensuring domestic tranquility and it can
be disruptive to tranquility I can
attest to that it's a real thing think
about it it's only been one month but
it's been a long month positive
interventions for cabin fever I'm gonna
take up running again it's an I used to
run back normal days before this job but
I'm going to start running again
my daughter Cara we're gonna run as a
family we're gonna go out there Kyra's
got a head start she's out there doing
five miles everyday she thinks she can
beat me give me a couple of weeks I'm
gonna be right there right there fast
like lightning I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
make the dog come the dog is also
experiencing cabin fever
sital disrupted the order of the pack
has changed different people he doesn't
know where he fits
yes anxiety he's gonna come out he's
gonna run think of ways to deal with it
I don't have any great answer but a
little perspective on the whole
situation is also important I challenged
my daughters this is terrible this is
terrible this is terrible this is
terrible I've been saying it's terrible
it's been terrible for society the
economy personally but you know let's
look back at history right generations
have gone through terrible times so my
challenge to them is you find me a
generation that has had a better overall
situation than where we are right now go
back world war one world war two Vietnam
1918 flu pandemic you find me a
generation that hasn't had
a challenge to deal with and we're going
to have that discussion and also keep in
mind on perspective this is going to be
over you see on this story developing
you can start to see how the story ends
right they will have a vaccine will it
be 12 months or 14 months or 18 months
there are a number of treatments that
are being expedited and are being tested
right now
dr. Zucker New York is working
expeditiously and cooperatively with the
FDA to try all new different treatments
the convalescent plasma receptor
antibody treatment we're working on the
hydroxychloroquine we're working on
aggressively so we're trying all these
new treatments some of them show real
promise but you can see that where the
story ends
I think misses opinion the fact I think
you see the return to normalcy when we
have an approved rapid testing program
that can be brought to scale we're now
testing rapid testing programs but when
you get to the point where you can do
rapid testing of scale and people can
start to go back to work because they
know they're negative we continue to
protect the vulnerable population which
is where this was about but we liberate
as my daughter's would say they're
seeking liberation we liberate people
who can go back to work because we know
that they're not in a vulnerable
category and they're negative and I
think that is it's under development now
the rapid testing and with tests and it
and we're part of it but that is going
to be the answer I believe and we get
through it because we are New York State
tough thank you in terms of the data
that you're saying is 594 which is a
slight dip from yesterday how many
straight days would you say or statists
I you would need to see sort of
similar numbers to say that we've had
the apex yeah Jesse you guys think I
don't give you straight answers you have
to talk to these statisticians they will
not give you a direct answer on anything
we don't know see well when you start
with the first two options it's either
straight up and straight down right or a
total V or maybe it's up with a plateau
and we're somewhere on the plateau they
don't know that's right they don't know
so maybe if you look at this three-day
roll as opposed to day to day you could
argue that you're seeing a plateauing
but they want to find out they want the
future data to determine if this was a
plateau so in other words next week
they'll tell you after they have a few
days whether we're on a plateau or was
just a blip is that accurate